[Music]
back in 2019 i made a video comparing
the irishman and goodfellas this long
steadicam tracking shot is undeniably
reminiscent of two shots from goodfellas
a core premise of my video was that
martin scorsese is creating meaning by
contrasting the way he uses long
tracking shots in the two films by using
the same technique to illustrate a
gangster alone at the end of his life
scorsese is drawing extra attention to
the emptiness and fleeting nature of
those benefits and to the different
perspective that the irishman will be
taking on its subject matter then a
little while ago i was watching an
interview and he says this um i knew it
had to start that way and i knew people
would say well that reminds me of the
shop in the copacabana has nothing to do
with i just have to find this guy
sitting there you know um and let's just
go through this
um uh this retired living
likes with the camera you've been
revealed as a shameless comment saying
you're over analyzing things are
actually true to do it
this video is sponsored by movie go to
movie.com thomasflight for your 30-day
extended free trial
in the big fight scene from noah
bombach's marriage story scarlett
johansson's character is offered a
choice between beer water and a juice
box you want something to drink she
chooses the juice box and eventually
sets it down and it appears here in the
last shot of the scene what does this
juice box symbolize what does it mean we
can take a guess her choice of juice box
contrasts charlie's choice of beer
showing she's taking a more sober
approach to this conversation but how do
we know this interpretation or analysis
is valid
david f samberg the director of
annabelle creation and shazam
occasionally makes youtube videos and
video essays in this video he talks
about how a lot of movie details can
just end up being the byproduct of
having to solve certain problems on set
this exterior location is scheduled to
shoot early on and turns out we don't
have faith who plays darla because she's
still on another show and at the end of
the video he mentions how this has
affected the way he views video essays
but working with movies has
kind of ruined video essays and film
analysis a little bit for me because
you just never know if something was
part of a brilliant plan or if it just
happened to turn out that way because a
problem had to be solved on the day
in shazam darla has a clearly defined
arc early on we see her being the
slowest of the foster kids which is of
course the setup to the payoff of her
getting super speed powers later on
yeah yeah
yeah
yes
so from that perspective we can't or
maybe we shouldn't read too much into
the juice box maybe the juice box
doesn't symbolize anything noah bombach
just wrote that there would be three
options and the production department
chose the first three things they could
grab maybe scarlett johansson just
prefers juice but then the same day i
watched sandberg's video i ran across
this video of noah bombach breaking down
the scene the juice box initially came
from the fact that i thought well okay
well charlie's living here alone he
doesn't have much and she ends up making
her way over to this chair here and and
laying it down on the floor this all
leads to the final shot of the scene
which is this wide shot as he falls to
the ground and i felt like the juice box
is henry's presence
in their lives and in our lives as an
audience you know that he's not in this
scene he's not here but
but he is there and he's really
powerless in this situation so maybe we
should say the juice box symbolizes
henry's presence in the room or does it
how do we know the correct
interpretation of a scene and who gets
to decide what something actually means
i absolutely get david samberg's point
not everything in every film is meant to
have some kind of deeper subtext and
sometimes critics or viewers or fans do
read into stuff that wasn't intentional
but simultaneously there are some
directors who can and do put an
incredible amount of thought into every
little detail and choice they make but
asking if a choice was intentional to
determine if an interpretation or
analysis is valid implies that the
meaning of something in a film is
entirely defined by the intention of the
director but somebody might watch this
scene from marriage story and think that
her choice of a juice box is a symbol of
her being childish despite what noah
bombach intends so where do we draw the
line does a director's intent for a
creative choice matter when we're
determining the meaning of a film yeah
yes
the answer of course is
it's complicated
there are some people who take the
director's creative intent as the final
infallible word for a film these people
are essentially treating the director's
word as objective truths about what a
film means and if your interpretation or
experience as a viewer differs from that
intent well then your interpretation is
wrong because of this some directors
knowing that anything they say will
become the de facto official
interpretation to a lot of people choose
to keep silent to maintain a degree of
ambiguity and force the audience to
interpret things for themselves believe
it or not eraserhead is my most
spiritual film
elaborate on that no i won't
but does the director if they choose to
talk about it actually have the final
say about what something in a film means
i don't think so i don't think intent
automatically equals meaning for several
reasons for one thing as much as some
directors want to have dictatorial
control on a set they usually don't many
hands go into making a film and many
different people make creative choices
that end up in the final film there are
a lot of examples of directors and
actors actually disagreeing on their own
personal interpretations of a character
or a scene in a film harrison ford and
ridley scott famously disagree over
whether deckard is a replicant in blade
runner so if we as the viewer are
looking at the film and trying to
determine which of those is the case
there's actually competing intense in
the film more recently in mid-summer
director ari astor and florence pugh
said they disagree about what the
character is experiencing in the film's
final moments as the audience we don't
know what the character is really
thinking we have to interpret that based
on what's on screen so if aster and pew
both had different intentions which
defines what is on screen while the
director usually has the most control it
doesn't really make sense to look to one
person as having the final say in what
every little thing in a film means but
there's another reason why director's
intent can't be the final word for what
a film means just because a director
intends something doesn't mean that's
actually what comes across on screen
sometimes there's a big disconnect
between the intention and how a film is
perceived by a lot of people a portion
of the matrix resurrection is spent
addressing this very issue they took
your story something that meant
so much to people like me
and turned it into something trivial the
way culture broadly interpreted and
understood the original matrix didn't
line up with the wachowski's intent when
someone watches a film their
interpretation of what that film means
unless they've consumed behind the
scenes content ahead of time simply
comes from the film itself its
relationship to other pieces of art and
movies that that person has consumed and
their own personal life experience and
if you walk away from a film with a
certain interpretation and you find out
later that the director intended
something entirely different does that
invalidate your initial feeling and
experience of the film i don't think so
all that means is that you read
something different from the director's
intent for the film that could be
because of your personal bias and
experiences and perspective or it could
be because the director actually did a
bad job of translating their intent into
the film now you might change your mind
about a film after you hear other
perspectives or go back and re-watch it
but you can't erase the initial
experience and feeling you had about the
film and finally i think one of the most
important reasons we can't rely on a
director or author as the final say for
what something means is because meaning
appears in things even when people
aren't trying to put it there when we
talk about what a juice box means or the
significance of a certain type of
tracking shot we're not talking about a
film's explicit meaning we're talking
about implicit meaning meaning that's
insinuated through abstraction and
symbolism for example in parasite nobody
is arguing about whether the lower class
family actually lives in a semi-basement
home that's part of the explicit meaning
of the film but you could say that that
family's position geographically as
lower than the rich family is a symbol
of their class that's an implicit
meaning and in a lot of cases implicit
meaning can actually even be pretty
clear but it's much more open to debate
than explicit meaning an implicit
meaning can creep into a story even when
the author isn't intending for it to be
there maybe they didn't know why they
were making a certain creative decision
but it just felt right at the time or
maybe cultural norms or pressures led
them to craft the story in a certain way
but either way there can still be
reasons why certain creative decisions
were made even if the author or the
filmmaker wasn't explicitly conscious of
them as they were making them and as a
viewer sometimes we notice and pick up
on these things where the filmmakers
didn't sometimes critics or film
scholars call this kind of meaning
symptomatic meaning and it can go very
deep into a film a film can tell us
things about a culture a time and place
or the director even when the film
itself is not trying to communicate
those things intentionally going back to
the irishman score says he can say that
he didn't mean for the use of the
tracking shot in the irishman to be a
callback to goodfellas but regardless of
what he intended i think it literally is
he's a director using the same kind of
shot decades apart in two different
gangster films and using the same kind
of shot for different purposes
highlights the difference between the
two films whether scorsese likes it or
not score says he might just be thinking
about it as the best way to shoot the
scene but to me the clear difference in
how he applied that technique says a lot
about the kind of story he's trying to
tell in the irishman versus the story he
was trying to tell in goodfellas and his
evolution as a filmmaker and person
between those two films at least that's
what it did for me when i saw the film
now i am wrong in the video where i
assert that scorsese used the tracking
shot intentionally to create this
contrast but that's a different issue
that doesn't have to do with whether or
not that thing is actually meaningful
just with whether or not i properly
attributed why it's happening in these
kinds of scenarios there's a certain
amount of guesswork involved and if i
think something is meaningful i'd rather
accidentally attribute it to being
intentional than say something was a
happy accident when the director
actually meant for it to be the case but
does this mean that every interpretation
of a film is equally valuable and that a
movie can just mean whatever somebody
wants it to mean
well i wouldn't say that any
individual's experience of a film is
technically invalid that doesn't mean
that that one person has the right to
insinuate that their interpretation is
the universally correct one i think
people put forth interpretations of
films and the value of a given
interpretation lies in how well that
interpretation resonates with other
people and whether it expands people's
understanding of the film then over time
generally we'll develop a loose set of
culturally accepted interpretations for
a given film by comparing different
people's experiences and interpretations
and maybe taking into account what the
director's intent was if they talk about
it and if somebody's single individual
interpretation is way off that mark will
probably say they're wrong find it
ridiculous or just disregard that
interpretation as not valuable for
example you could say that to you
parasite is a celebration of capitalism
but most people would just disagree with
you but i'd go so far as to say that you
don't personally get to choose what your
interpretation of a film is you can say
a film means whatever you want but if
what you say a film means doesn't align
with your personal experience of the
film you can't force yourself to
experience the film in a certain way for
example if you watch bambi and you find
it sad and you cry every time you can't
suddenly decide that bambi is a comedy
and find it really funny and i think
good interpretation in large part is
just being able to honestly convey your
understanding of a film to other people
you do analysis to try to figure out why
you experienced a film in a certain way
not to figure out what that experience
was and a good analysis or
interpretation will resonate even with
somebody who disagrees with you because
you'll do such a good job of explaining
or arguing for why you experienced it
that way but does all this mean that a
director's creative intent is
meaningless and that we should just look
at our own experience and feelings about
a film i don't think so knowing a
director's creative intent and other
people's interpretations helps us better
understand the language of film and the
process of communicating a certain
intent on screen it's easy to want there
to be a clear objective way of
evaluating things but instead we're
stuck with this messy collaborative
process of putting forth our individual
perspectives comparing notes and then
trying to come to some kind of consensus
as a group we strive to develop an idea
of objective quality even though this is
technically unattainable because it
helps us develop a common visual
language and grammar we can use to make
art that resonates with other people but
ultimately no one owns the final say on
a given work of art not even the
director you have to evaluate the work
and other people's interpretations for
yourself thank you so much to mubi for
sponsoring this video if you want to
really understand how competing in
tension can exist in the same piece i
definitely recommend checking out
meeting the man james baldwin in paris
you've veered the film off your literary
work and on to
what you feel it's a short little
documentary but it's a fascinating look
at how the directors of the documentary
come into conflict with the subject of
the documentary james baldwin and
there's kind of a little bit of a
competition over whose message is going
to get across movie doesn't just have
documentaries they have international
indie cinema festival favorites a huge
incredible selection that they hand pick
for you and they add a new film every
day mubi is a great place to go just to
find something new inventive and
interesting to watch when you sign up
using my link you can get a 30-day
extended free trial so you have no
excuse not to try it out go to mubi.com
thomasflight that's movie.com
thomasflight or click the link in the
description or on the screen to sign up
today
[Music]